les menaces se multiplient tel pour les
banques on en parle avec vous laurent
mignon bonjour bonjour tchèque
installez-vous merci merci président du
groupe bpce banque populaire caisse
d'epargne ont parlé juste avant de
l'incursion des incursions des gaffes à
dans les services bancaires dans le
domaine de la finance notamment
évidemment aux états unis est ce que
vous prenez ces menaces au sérieux au vu
j'ai envie de dire de leur force de
frappe financière de leur savoir faire
technologique ou même pas peur non je
crois qu'il faut prendre ça très au
sérieux les gaffes à comme vous le
soulignez elles ont beaucoup de moyens
financiers elles ont surtout une une
très grande habitude de la relation
client donc c'est des gens à prendre
très au sérieux il faut être concentré
il faut se développer sa propre
stratégie et nous avons des stratégies
digitales importante nous digitalise on
aux banques pour qu'elles puissent
répondre aux attentes des clients nous
le groupe bpce par exemple on a pris une
stratégie assez original qui est de ne
pas vouloir développer une banque
directe une banque une banque purement
digital on a décidé de digitaliser nos
relations bancaires de toutes nos
agences des caisses d'epargne et des
banques populaires c'est une stratégie
qu'on appelle digital inside et qui fait
que aujourd'hui les applications des
banques populaires les applications des
caisses d'epargne sont parmi les mieux
notés du marché aussi bien que celle
d'aider des néo banques
les plus recherchés donc juste encore
une fois on voit que apple s'est allié à
goldman sachs pour lancer une carte
bancaire aux états unis là encore une
fois vous associés pour lancer une carte
bancaire avec apple vous dit pourquoi
pas ou fermer la porte n'ont en
l'occurence j'ai pas besoin d'apple pour
développer une carte bancaire donc en
l'occurrence aux etats unis apple s'est
associé avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas une
banque de détail donc s'il faisait il
entrerait dans le marché de la la
concurrence directe avec de beaux je
suis pas sûr que les gars fois
aujourd'hui et de l'intention de rentrer
dans le marché bancaire rit-elle en
europe le coeur de notre modèle c'est la
relation client c'est cette proximité
que nous sommes capables de nous et avec
lui grâce à notre proximité de nos
agences de 2,2 encore une fois caisse
d'epargne-banque populaire le rôle du
conseiller qui est demandé par nos
clients on voit d'ailleurs en sortie de
crise les gens
souhaite une proximité une capacité de
dialoguer avec un conseiller mais il
souhaite aussi pouvoir faire leur banque
à distance aujourd'hui 80 % de nos
clients utilisent des canaux dit gino
dort banque tous les jours et s'accroît
fortement donc il faut pouvoir leur
offrir les deux et appartements monde
fait bien il n'y a pas de raison un
penser que nos modèles sont en danger si
on continue à investir après selon kpmg
68% c'est pas rien des clients seraient
prêts à faire de leur nez aux banques
donc digital leur banque principale si
tous les services bancaires étaient
proposées est ce que à terme quand même
peut-être un thème rapprocher ces
banques en ligne c'est nos banques vont
vous faire de l'ombre elle nous force à
vous présenter à nous exactement elle
nous force à à elle nous fuit elle vous
dimanche de laine sur le dos oui mais
pas tant que ça aujourd'hui nous gagnons
des clients globalement nous continuons
angles et gagner les cuirs et donc
elle nous force à nous réinventer elle
nous pousse à penser différemment les
choses et de ce point de vue là c'est
positif moi je vous donne un exemple
pendant la locaux vides qu'est-ce qui
était aux côtés des français pour les
aider qu'est ce qui a aidé des
entreprises françaises à traverser cette
crise c'est lé nos banques nous c'était
les banques de proximité c'est nous qui
avons fait des paies jeu qui avons
accompagné les artisans les pros pendant
cette période là c'est pas des néo beau
cette proximité là ses capacités à bien
connaître le besoin du client elle est
indispensable je ne dis pas que les néo
banques peuvent pas apporter de 2,2 à
l'heure et des choses mais pour
l'instant d'abord aucune d'entre elles
n'a démontré un modèle économique viable
et la route probable et puis oui mais
bon et nous par ailleurs nous faisons
les investissements pour pouvoir avoir
la même qualité de service que ce
qu'elle offre il ya concurrence des
banques digital en mignon il ya les
contraintes réglementaires faut en
parler parce que quelque part est ce que
c'est une aux banques elles sont
réglementées comme une banque peut
l'être on dit qu'être banquiers et je
suis pas là pour vous plaindre mais dire
que c'est beaucoup de paperasse et
beaucoup de fonds propres assez sûrement
beaucoup de fonds propres c'est la
paperasse youn moins en moins mais c'est
beaucoup de 2 deux procédures de
vérification vous avez on nous on doit
vraiment nous assurer à chaque fois
qu'on fait des transactions on peut
montrer l'origine des fonds toutes ces
choses là qu'on a une très bonne
connaissance de nos clients donc ça
s'appelle know your customer en anglais
bon bah tous ces procédures là sont des
procédures qui sont aujourd'hui très
intégrés dans les processus des grandes
banques probablement pas encore toujours
dans les haubans qui veulent plutôt
favoriser la rapidité de 2,2 d'ouverture
de la session et est progressivement
elles sont réguliers de la même façon et
donc ces sujets là les gratins mais
je crois que nous aujourd'hui le il faut
pas se dire que la régulation est ce qui
va nous protéger comme une baril à mort
arrive c'est une question que vous avez
avec votre jeu de la 2e la devance allez
un petit peu la fin pas spécialement en
tout cas bien sûr que ça les règlements
facile donc c'est pour ça que les gaffes
à aujourd'hui elle attaque plutôt sur
des services qui sont hors régulation
par exemple les paiements qui est un
sujet voix lors il est régulier mais de
façon beaucoup plus légère et ça c'est
un enjeu très important et le sujet des
paiements est un et 1 est un est un
débat de deux majeurs deux souverainetés
d'ailleurs pour le pôle europe des
banques condamnées à se réinventer parce
qu'il ya tout ce qu'on a dit la de cette
concurrence le contexte réglementaire
les taux d'intérêt bas on c'est vrai
qu'on va en sortir saron vos marges
d'intérêts ce que le métier de banquier
j pas qu'il est menacé mais ce qu'il est
corseté par tout ça vous avez des
condamnés à se réinventer moi je pense
que se réinventer c'est toujours une
chance et c'est penser l'avenir
différemment faire progresser son
entreprise faire progresser sa relation
avec les clients et donc en l'occurrence
des aiguillons nous en avons un petit
mot laurent mignon des défis green aussi
qui s'opposent aux banques on l'a vu
dans le reportage en début d'émission
l'émergence de neo banque verte avec
l'engagement que l'argent confié finance
des projets qui sont durables et
responsables est ce que ça aussi c'est
un défi du jour au terme pour les
banques ouais enfin je pense que c'est
un défi pour la société majeur qui est
la transition vers une économie
décarbonée on attend les banques sur ce
sujet sûr qu'on attend des banques comme
on attend la société c'est une évolution
majeure ça va pas être quelque chose de
c'est une transition
et un matin ça mon nouveau qu'on est en
train d'inventer et c'est pas simplement
en finançant quelques éoliennes que ça
va se faire ou en finançant manière que
quelques parcs photovoltaïques bien peut
calculer son empreinte carbone quand on
est criant bpce bonjour à tous les
achats du quotidien non on peut pas
aujourd'hui mais mais c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourrait faire un jour c'est
mais fondamentalement le gros enjeu il
est beaucoup plus que dans le le
caractère ludique de savoir si c'est
comme ça qu'on change aussi dans
l'appartement quotidien est sûre ça fait
partie et toutes ces choses là font
partie de ski qui comme on dit qui
concourent à faire progresser la société
vers un monde décarboné mais ce monde
d'écart monnaie il va prendre du temps
et le gros enjeu nous avons c'est
accompagner nos clients dans la durée
sur la transition c'est une transition
on va pas passer d'une économie où les
voitures roulent
à l'essence à une économie où elle se
remet à tout le monde voilà à
l'électrique pur peut d'ailleurs que
c'est électrique étaient des produits de
manière qui soit propre et ça posera
d'ailleurs le sujet d'un taxonomie
européenne de tous qui derrière et sont
des sujets majeurs qui nécessite
beaucoup de travail qui sont très
sérieux dans lequel les institutions
financières doivent s'engager parce
qu'elles ont un rôle en orientant après
les parcs vers ses finances les défis
sont nombreux à relever pour les banques
très nombreux mais c'est ce qui fait que
c'est passionnant bon très bien merci
d'avoir été avec nous je laurent mignon
donc le président du groupe bpce banque
populaire caisse d'epargne merci
[Musique]